Oh
Five signs an ambivert likes you
With approximately two-thirds of the population being ambivert, chances are you've crossed path with your fair share throughout your life
maybe you even fit this category
an ambivert represents traits of both introversion and extraversion
meaning that while they enjoy social interactions and partying they also appreciate their time alone every once in a while
and Hey, maybe you don't fit this group, but you found yourself attracted to an ambivert and want to know if they return the feelings
Here are five signs an ambivert likes you
One, they single you out at large gatherings
Well ambiverts can find enjoyment from being around other people
They usually felt more at ease among smaller groups or having one-on-one conversations
If they've ever singled you out at a party
Chances are they are interested in interacting with you in a setting where they were most comfortable
Two
spontaneously asking you to hang out
Averts attitudes can change depending on whether they're on a work or school setting as opposed to a more social one
Because of this you might at first think them to be very introverted only to be surprised later when they ask you to come along
Maybe even with a few of your friends
This is because why ambiverts need their alone time
They might also find comfort in small groups in order to rest from their more solitary work environment
And because of the sudden bursts of extraversion. They might just work up the courage and ask you out
Three, they seem to be hesitating around you if an ambivert ever seems to be fluctuating in the attitude with which approach you
This might be why think of the introverted and extroverted sides of ambivert arguing over what's best for their social life
While one side might shy away from the social interaction their extroverted side really wants to stay and talk to you
It's not at all that they've changed their minds about you all of a sudden in fact
It's such an important decision for them. They can't let themselves take it lightly
This translates into their online interactions as well
for
inconsistent interactions online
An ambivert might stay up to talk to you until 5:00 a.m.. One day and then proceed to completely disappear from social media the next
Remember an ambivert needs their alone time as much as their social time
This behavior doesn't mean they've lost interest all of a sudden
Simply that they must recharge on their own with some alone time
If you can wait this out, they'll appreciate your patience as well as continue interacting with you once they're fully ready to be social again
five, they show you your playful side and their serious side
As your relationship with an ambivert deepens you start to discover more and more layers to their personality
This means the letting you into their own little world
Which can be a side completely different from the one you saw when you first met them perhaps?
They weren't very talkative before but as you got to know them they began to shoulder playful side
Aside of them that in the end is all part of the same person in the letting you in on all of this
Because they're comfortable around you
These are some signs and ambivert might like you have you met someone who has shown one or more signs around you
Maybe this list has helped clear some things up